A capacitor of capacitance c1 is charged up
to a potential v volt and then connected in
parallel to an uncharged capacitor of
capacitance c2. The final potential difference across each
capacitor will be. What will be the final
potential difference across each capacitor will be?  It will
tell you that the first capacitor has a
potential of c1, its
potential is v1 or v, the
second one has a capacitance of c2 and
what is its potential v2. It is zero
because there is no charge on it and the
entire charge is on it.  What is the common potential? What is the
common potential? Sir, c1 v1
+ c2 v2 / c1 + c2, now v1 is there, how much is v2, if it is
zero, then this thing will become zero, then
how much v will come? c1 v1 or c1v / c1 + c2, finished
option.  number b